John: Hi I'm John Hope Bryant, founder, chairman
and CEO of operation hope, and a young global
leader for the World Economic Forum.
I'm here in beautiful Jordan where I had the
chance to be here two years ago with Queen
Rania doing dignity day in local schools.
And Queen Rania when I saw these young girls
respond to her.
They opened up, they, they became like flowers.
And I was told that they would not talk to
me, these young girls would not say a word
to me.
But when I accorded them respect and the dignity
they deserved.
When I respected their intelligence and assumed
they had good ideas, it took a little bit,
but after about five minutes, a hand started
going up.
And then once one hand went up a half dozen
hands went up.
And they started engaging and involving in
the conversation.
So the window was Queen Rania -- the door
was Queen Rania, the window though was the
dignity that I accorded them, and then the
opportunity was really the brilliance of their
mind and their thought and their ideas.
And while I was told these young girls would
not say a word to me, after an hour and a
half I couldn't shut them up.
And so when they went to bring Queen Rania
in at the end of the session, and you can
-- a lot of this is caught on video.
You can go to Queen Rania's website and I
guess search dignity day Genev -- Jordan.
I asked them why can't -- you know why couldn't
we shut you up, what was, what was going on.
They said no one ever asked us our opinion.
No one ever asked us what we believed.
They tell us what we are supposed to believe,
and they don't seem genuinely interested in
what we have to say.
You seem genuinely interested in what we have
to say, and we see Queen Rania and we see
these other women.
They saw my wife who is an amazing woman.
She is a [inaudible] who owns her own business,
and has an incredible reputation and had a
business card, about how powerful it is to
have a business card.
And they, they said well if she can do that
then I can do that.
Not only Queen Rania, but here is, here is
another woman that we can relate to.
And here is a man that seems to accord us
respect as an equal.
So I think that's an example.
I think this is a universal issue.
I was with [inaudible] who is CEO of a beautiful
company here in the Middle East, Eremats.
And he's doing work in a settlement area here
in Jordan, and we went there.
And he was the only private sector leaders
that’s gone in this area.
So now he's opening a door and a window for
young people to become entrepreneurs or want
to become entrepreneurs.
To dream big dreams.
And to become dreamers with shovels in their
hands.
Shovels of ideas, shovels of ambition, shovels
of desire.
And to open up their horizons, to become entrepreneurs,
small business owners, self employment projects.
Because there's not enough jobs to go around
in Jordan nor the middle east, you'd need
100 million jobs to fill the void.
You have 60% of the population under 25, that's
not gonna change any time soon.
You've got to inspire a generation of entrepreneurs
and self employment projects and empowered
people.
You do that by changing the role models.
In changing what these kids see so they see
things differently.
I'll end with this.
This is not a Middle East problem.
I'm from the United States and in the inner
cities in the Unites States which look a lot
like the settlements, you have young people
who want to be drug dealers, athletes and
rap stars.
Now these kids aren't dumb and their not stupid,
they're very smart, they're modeling what
they see.
We need to give these kids something different
to see.
If you can get the role model level to 5%
-- The book tipping point by Gladwell says
that 5% role models, all communites stabilize.
The problem is most communities in the urban
areas have 3% role models, 3.7% role models
or less.
So it's too thin, so they model what they
see versus what they could be.
We can change in the US, we can change in
Europe, we can change in Latin America, we
can change it in Asia, we can change it here.
And I'm very hopeful, I'm very positive, I
love Jordan, I love being here and hopefully
you I don't know loved this presentation,
or only tolerated me for just a moment.
God bless.